hi guys so welcome to the 2018 fall
Allan bloom forum if you guys could all
put your cell phones on silent right now
we'd really appreciate that so my name
is Helen Zhou and I'm the president of
this semester's Allan bloom forum named
for the late philosopher classicist and
Yale professor Allan bloom bloom was a
champion of classical education grounded
in the great books of the Western canon
and he became famous for his criticism
of the moral education upheld by
institutions of higher learning in the
u.s. the Allan bloom forum at Yale seeks
to embody and share his spirit of both
critical inquiry and veneration of
intellectual pursuits as such the forum
seeks to promote the public exploration
of the ideas that have shaped both the
Western and American tradition
we invite distinguished guests from
academia politics and related
institutions to speak on issues of
culture philosophy history and politics
past guests have included Allen cores of
the University of Pennsylvania
Harvey Mansfield of Harvard and Robert P
George of Princeton we're honored this
year to be hosting dr. um hos OD dr.
ho's Oni specializes in political theory
philosophy and biblical studies he's
president of the Herzl Institute in
Jerusalem and founder of the Shalem
Center Israel's leading publisher of
Western philosophy translated into
Hebrew the center is now Salem College
the first accredited liberal arts
college in Israel doctoral zonies recent
work has appeared in publications such
as The Wall Street Journal the New York
Times the National Review and NPR he
even appeared with Morgan Freeman in his
National Geographic miniseries the story
of God where he illuminates the story of
Abraham and Isaac
tonight dr. hezonia will be addressing
the topic of his newest book the virtue
of nationalism
although nationalism today is often a
term that has been associated with
dangerous tribalism dr. ho's Oni seeks
to analyze it as a principle of shared
identity one that encourages people to
work towards upholding the ideals that
so characterized their nation the shared
identity can be cultivated through the
development of shared language history
and religion thus at a time when many
have deemed the nation-state to be
obsolete dr. hezonia argues in
debt that it is in fact an important
unit of economic interest and political
action as well as an important
moralizing agent and the best mode of
organizing society today the virtue of
nationalism has received critical
acclaim and leading Minds have
emphasized the value of Doctor Who's
oneis philosophy especially in our
current political moment michael lind
co-founder the think-tank New America
wrote that in a time when nationalism is
all too often conflated with racism and
authoritarianism euro Mazzoni reminds us
that democracy and Liberty can flourish
only in a world of sovereign
nation-states anat on Sharansky a
notable human rights activist and author
of the case for democracy and defending
identity has commented that political
figures scholars and the broader public
will have to think carefully about this
remarkable book now without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. your
Amazonian all right can you hear this
okay here's what's gonna happen what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna start talking
and then when I start getting excited
I'll start lowering the microphone and
that'll you'll be able to hear less so I
don't when I do that I don't know wave
at me or something to remind me that I'm
forgetting myself all right well it's
exciting to be here at Yale some of you
may know that my history is at another
school I went to Princeton my wife went
to Princeton my daughter went to
Princeton so I would like to thank you
all in this era of intolerance for the
gracious warm welcome that I received
this evening from the Yale students I
really really do appreciate it
and in fact I appreciate anybody who's
tolerant in this day and age
so speaking of intolerance I'm talking
to you about nationalism the week that
President Trump announced that he was a
nationalist I wrote the book before
President Trump and
that he was a nationalist so I didn't
have didn't didn't have him his
declaration in mind and nevertheless I
thought that the points that he made
about nationalism were exactly on like
you'd I don't I don't think you have to
love him or agree with everything that
he thinks or says in order to agree with
with this points on nationalism maybe
other things and and I find it
absolutely incredible that that someone
can take what I consider to be and I
think traditionally historically was a
reasonable position with respect to the
independence of nations and the
desirability of a world of independent
nations and and be widely condemned as
as a Nazi as Hitler not not just by you
know by people I don't know if students
let's say who are excited and and and
don't know the stuff well yet but in the
most prestigious and the most important
forums and the most important media in
the country people don't have any
problem declaring that the president is
something is something like a Nazi and
why because he thinks that we should
take a stand on the issue of globalism
versus nationalism and he thinks that we
should take the nationalist side now I
think that he's completely right on this
nationalism versus globalism is the
issue of our age it's the most important
political issue that that that there is
and every one of us if we want to be
responsible about about our political
views about our position on public
matters if we want to be responsible
then we're going to have to each one of
us is going to have to take a stand on
exactly this question of globalism
versus nationalism where do we stand
okay so that's the subject that I'm
going to talk about this evening before
I get into the substance of it let me
just say that the
the political spectrum in America has
has shifted to the left on this and many
other issues in the last generation in
in a way that's that's pretty
extraordinary when I was in college
Ronald Reagan was president Margaret
Thatcher was the Prime Minister in the
UK and I I think that you could just use
the word nationalist I mean let's for
example Reagan was elected and
commentary magazine which in those days
was the flagship publication of American
conservative thought of serious American
conservative thought commentary magazine
welcomed Ronald Reagan for the new
nationalism that he was bringing to
America that was that the the praise for
Reagan was look at this great new
nationalism that he's reviving in the
country and Irving Kristol who was in
those days considered kind of the the
the the leading intellectual of public
conservatism in America maybe you could
say Buckley but one of the two was and
it was was well-known for for his view
that conservatism modern conservatism
rests on three pillars religion
nationalism and economic growth and in
fact he was famous for writing a book
called two cheers for capitalism because
he thought that capitalism was important
as as an engine for economic growth and
there wasn't any better system but why
not three cheers because he thought that
without a strong bulwark of religion and
nationalism that the the corrosive
effects of of the free market would end
up undermining the family and the nation
and religious tradition which is exactly
what has happened you could argue so in
those days when when I became a
conservative when I was in sort of
inducted into the conservative movement
and nationalism was a normal thing for a
person to be now what's
changed is that over the last 30 years
since the fall of the Berlin Wall
something pretty remarkable happened
they went when I was in college we were
still in the middle of the struggle
against the Soviet Union the the free
nations as they were called right this
is this is what America and its allies
called themselves the free nations saw
themselves as being pitted against what
Reagan called the evil empire right and
notice the difference between Empire and
nations to be free was to have your own
nation to be independent to do your own
thing to to be part of an evil empire
was to have some central ideology the
dictated wanted to dictate to to every
people that it conquered how they would
live in what they would think and that
whose goal was to take over the entire
world and dictate to everyone in the
world what they would think and what
they would believe in how they would
live and the people people who were
fighting on the free nation side of this
and I I'm speaking from from
conversations of people who were
involved in the the administration then
and and remember this time and say we we
always thought that that we were the
good guys because our goal was to set
the nations of the world free now so
when the Berlin Wall fell in 1989 there
was this moment where there were people
who said the war is over we won
let's let's bring the boys home let's go
home and let's take care of the the the
crumbling cultural institutions in in
our country that need for us urgently to
to to deal with them people like Irving
Kristol and if you if you go and read
reflections of a neoconservative today
it's like on many points it's like
reading President Trump is looking for
the withering away of NATO and on many
points of course it's the higher at a
higher level of diction but it's a lot
like like the things that we so
today disparagingly with Trump's
nationalism so people people like
crystal and Jean Kirkpatrick wanted the
war to end and wanted some kind of
return to to taking care of of business
at home but that point of view was swept
away Margaret Thatcher it was one of
along with Reagan one of the principal
the principal moral forces you can add
the Pope I guess but one of the one of
the one of the principal moral forces of
the the struggle against Empire right
Reagan Thatcher Pope John Paul this
position that she had as a leading
campaigner against the Soviet Union
should have I don't know if you know as
as I'm not a Brit
right it wasn't living in the UK but
looking at it from abroad
you would think wow since Churchill the
British have not had a leader like
Margaret Thatcher but the moment the war
ended she was dumped and what she was
dumped particularly there there were
some domestic issues but the central
thing that made her just absolutely
intolerable was the fact that she was a
nationalist was the fact that she was
struggling to try to prevent the United
Kingdom from giving up its sovereignty
to the European Union and being
submerged into this into this
international organization whose aim was
to expropriate the independence of
nations to end the independence of
nations and to impose a uniform rule of
law and ideas on them by the time that
Margaret Thatcher was dumped by her own
political party by the Conservatives
there was just about no one who was
willing to take a stand I mean almost
nobody no mainstream significant
political figure was willing to take a
stand against what today looking back on
it I think we can see was a moment of
extraordinary utopianism
utopianism like the the flood of books
declaring the end of history and that
the world was about to to become one
world with one economy and everyone was
going to unite under a single
international law George HW Bush
declared declared the in 1991 the new
world order and I can remember to this
day the the the the the shiver that went
down my spine when I heard the President
of the United States talking about this
new world order he said for a thousand
generations mankind has struggled but
failed to achieve what we're about to
achieve now anytime somebody starts
talking to you about a thousand
generations and they're going to solve
the problems that that thousand
generations couldn't have solved if
you're good conservative like all the oh
all the alarms should be going on all of
them a thousand generations and what was
he going to solve what's this new world
order he said the the law of the jungle
was no longer going to rule in the world
instead it would be replaced by the rule
of law so that's his vision is that the
entire planet was going to be wrapped in
a rule of law which was going to emanate
from the Security Council of the United
Nations later American presidents back
down from from that view of the
centrality of the Security Council is
kind of like a super legislature but all
the subsequent American presidents up
until Trump and all of the the the
British leaders up until up until brexit
all of them bought into this so
Democrats and Republicans labor and
conservatives and all the major parties
across Europe all of them miraculously
reached this uncanny unanimity that what
was needed was to take down the borders
and create a single a single economic
and political order for the for the
entire planet goes under different names
some people call it global
some people call it liberal
internationalism I call it liberal
Empire and I'll explain myself in a
moment okay but this vision of one world
under one law to be enforced if
necessary by American might you know
with European contingents but by
American might that was the political
vision of the the political leadership
of all major parties for thirty years
for almost thirty years now I think that
this is a horrendous and just a terrible
terrible mistake and I'd like to talk to
you about two two aspects of this
mistake first I want to say something
about the history of the idea of
nationalism as opposed to imperialism
and then I'd like to talk a little bit
about the the political theory of the
the political philosophy of of
nationalism and then we'll have a
conversation if you still have patience
for it after all that all right so first
let's begin with the historical issue
the the history of the West can be of
Western nations can be seen as a kind of
a seesaw between imperialism and
nationalism this seesaw begins with the
Hebrew Bible with the Old Testament in
if you study the Bible and I personally
think it's a a great mistake that
political theory depart a court it's the
political theory departments and and
programs and and philosophy programs and
and and and law faculty do not consider
the Bible to be worthy of study for its
ideas because many of its ideas are
decisive in the history of the West and
even if you don't agree with any of them
at least to know where they come from
would be a useful thing so one of the
ideas that is is extremely significant
in the history of the West that derives
from Hebrew Hebrew Scripture is the idea
of the independent national states right
in prior prior to that we have in the
Middle East as far as the Bible can see
we
have you know try tribes and clans you
know like Abraham going and living on a
mountaintop in a tent with with goats
and sheep and when is it when he feels
like going to war against some some King
he gathers up the neighbors and you know
like a posse and they they go out in
they wage war every family has if you
live in the order that that ancient
order of tribes and clans every family
has like its own foreign policy all
right but that is a that is a life of
Anarchy that is a life of violence and
so the the Middle East by the time that
that the Bible is being composed the
Middle East is has seen a succession of
visionary empires the Egyptian Empire
the Babylonian Empire the Assyrian
Empire the Persian Empire some of them
go more than one round and all of these
empires when you start digging when you
start digging into the sands in the
Middle East and you pull up these clay
tablets you start reading what what
they're writing about
although these empires are you know in
many ways very different from one
another they all share a they all share
a single vision for the relationship
between between the gods and and world
Empire the vision is the gods come and
say to Pharaoh or Hammurabi or
Nebuchadnezzar that the gods come and
say to to the king to the Emperor I want
you to go out and suppress the needless
division and violence throughout the
world because people are killing each
other for no reason your mission is to
conquer the four corners of the earth
that's the expression that keeps
appearing to conquer the four corners of
the earth and to bring peace and
prosperity to all mankind that is the
Imperial vision and that imperial vision
it we see we see it later it's adopted
by Alexander the Great and his effort to
try to unify mankind and then it becomes
the the vision of the Roman Empire and
from the Roman Empire it gets adopted by
the by
the Holy Roman Empire right it becomes
the the the the medieval Catholic vision
of a universal Catholic Republic it also
becomes the the vision of the caliphate
right the Islamic world Republic and
then later it gets picked up by all
sorts of characters right like Napoleon
who is going to bring peace and
prosperity enlightenment to the world by
imposing French enlightenment and by
Hitler who is going to make he says is
going to make Germany Lord of the earth
and mistress of the globe all of these
all of these are imitations of the Roman
Empire the Russians also have a
tradition of being the third Rome of a
vision of of unifying the world under
Russian leadership which you know later
transmogrifies into into the crazy
communist vision but you can just go on
and on now in this background of of this
dream of unifying mankind and bring
being bringing peace and prosperity
against this the only texts that we have
from antiquity that stand up against
this vision the only texts are not Greek
and not Roman they're the texts we find
in the Hebrew Bible and in the Hebrew
Bible that this is despite the fact that
the the Jews are famous for you know for
their their monotheism right for for
discovering the God of heaven and earth
who is was the father of all mankind and
the Creator the Creator and the father
of all mankind
despite this notice this incredible
thing that God creator of heaven and
earth speaks to Moses but he doesn't
tell him what all the other gods tell
him go out and conquer the four corners
of the earth
in fact what he tells him is the
opposite he says here are the borders
that your people will live within and he
gives them the Torah and the Torres you
know it's for all mankind the the the
biblical teaching is clearly for all
mankind
but Moses is told you'll you have
borders and in Deuteronomy he tells the
the people of Israel do not trouble the
neighbors do because God has given them
their lands as an inheritance and so you
leave them alone if you bother them you
get punished the God of Israel as far as
we know is the first God in the history
of mankind to give borders to his own
people and say no you're not allowed to
go and conquer the neighbors he says you
should have a king who's from among your
brothers
you should have prophets who are from
among your brothers that doesn't mean
that there aren't prophets among the
other nations it just means that your
prophets are gonna be from your people
and other people will have their own
kings and their own prophets in this
vision and as far as the universal
teaching that the Jews are supposed to
bring into the world the prophets say
when they are ready the peoples will
come to Jerusalem and they'll study with
you alright this is this is a a
revolution in the history of politics
morals and theology this idea that you
think you know the truth you think you
know God's will but you have no right to
go conquer the neighbors and impose it
on them when they're ready they'll come
to you now as I said Western history is
kind of a seesaw for most of Western
history what we get is is Empire and
more Empire but the Hebrew Bible the Old
Testament never stops causing trouble
for for this vision of empire even in
the Middle Ages Catholics we see the the
French the English the poles the Czechs
developing nationalisms developing a
resistance struggling against against
centralization against the holy roman
empire against the popes and this really
comes to to an explosive place with the
protestant reformation especially the
Western Protestants the Calvinists the
Anglicans in 1534 when Henry the eighth
the
Claire's independence from the Holy
Roman Empire we're all taught that it's
all about Anne Boleyn or something I'm I
have no doubt that she played an
important role but if the English had
not already for centuries seen of
themselves as something like an
independent nation there never would
have been a Declaration of Independence
it wouldn't have been possible to do but
the English adopted it they embraced it
after the English we we see the Dutch
fighting a war of independence from from
Spanish Spanish imperialism from the
Holy Roman Empire Spanish branch for 81
years read the Dutch Declaration of
Independence of 1581 it's 200 years
before the American Declaration of
Independence the similarities are
absolutely uncanny Jefferson might have
been cribbing it's amazing it's amazing
the similarities and the Scots declare
independence the Swiss and the French
and so on now this is the beginning of a
world in which national independence and
the view of a world of independent
nations which later what we call
nationalism this is the moment that it
first gets put on the table as something
that might actually happen I mean in in
in the Bible it was maybe something that
might actually happen but the
Protestants really do succeed in pulling
off one nation national state after
another the United States is is one of
these countries and for 300 years three
four hundred years we we have now this
is a new world order this is a a world
in which gradually the principle of each
nation should seek its own course and be
allowed to do that by its neighbors
right gradually becomes accepted and
becomes the basis of international
politics now obviously there's an awful
lot of flaws in that implementation I
mean while while the Europeans are like
developing this theory of independent
national states at the same time they
start building empires they don't have a
problem conquering you know Africans and
Americans and Asians often brutally so
I'm not trying to paint this as some
kind of ideal or something it
at the same time this principle of the
independence of Nations eventually
demolishes these empires eventually it
gets strong enough so that it ends
colonialism now was this good was this
for the good this this this movement of
what Henry Kissinger calls the the [ __ ]
in his book World Order which is
excellent from 2015 if you're scared of
all those gigantic Henry Kissinger books
this world order book it's like a
summary of all of his vast volumes it's
super please read it so he Henry
Kissinger says up until the treaty's the
Westphalia treaties in 1648 up until
then the whole European history is
though the whole world in fact is just a
battle between among contending
Universal isms every single every single
power wants to be the universal power
and conquer all the others and here this
this this biblical vision allows for
treaties which actually explicitly allow
that whether you're a Lutheran or
Calvinist or a Catholic nation that's no
longer going to be an excuse to go to
war I'm not saying they banned wars they
had plenty of wars but the the impulse
to say you have to live the way I say
takes the first step towards a world
that is much more tolerant and that has
a direct effect very quickly also on
tolerance internally in countries all
right so we live in a world that was
created by this moment how did that work
this new world of competition among
nations I think in a lot of ways it
worked great the many of the things that
we consider to be the you know the the
flower of what's good about modernity
the-the-the the intense advancement in
the sciences the new experiments and
innovations in government in economics
in industry and in art we see the
competition among these newly
independent nations as creating this
kind of
hot house of X H one is an experiment
and what it means to be human and they
compete with one another and trying to
better the world again I'm not saying
anything's perfect about it this is not
a utopian vision that I'm describing my
book is not utopian there's plenty of
things wrong this is not going to solve
all the problems in the world but
compared to what there was I think in
many ways it's a great advancement let's
think about this advancement just a
little bit I say that that these are
competing Nations right this is the age
of the balance of power this is the age
in which the idea gets developed and
advanced by thinkers like Vittal for
example who writes that the key to the
European system is to prevent any one
power from gaining control over the
others now
when I study did this in college maybe
you heard the same thing the balance of
power is described I think almost always
as though its purpose is to bring peace
and stability but I looked this up
actually and if I tell doesn't say
anything of the kind
he says something much more interesting
he doesn't claim that this brings peace
and stability what he claims is that it
brings freedom that by having by
preventing anyone power from growing
strong enough to be able to he says to
dictate the law to the others you
maintain freedom in the system the whole
purpose and the balance of power is to
prevent an imperial power from being
able to dictate the law to the rest of
the planet now let's think about this a
second I said that some of the great
innovations in government and economics
the kinds of things that that we often
hear liberals talking about limited
government democratic rotation of power
among competing groups within it within
the nation the the the the concern for
individual liberties oh the the free
market all of these things are developed
where where are they developed they
develop in these independent national
states now of course they each of the
thing
I mentioned has a prehistory that goes
all the way back to the Bible and
through medieval political theory it
didn't spring out of nowhere at the same
time it's these independent and this is
not a coincidence that it's in England
and Scotland and the Netherlands and in
America it's an independent national
states that we find the development of
all of these things that liberals say
well look this is this is what makes for
a good life we don't have a single
example in all of human history not one
not one example of limited government
being developed and implemented as a
principle for an entire empire for an
empire for a state that wants to conquer
many nations all right let me just
refine these terms for a second
nationalism the view that the world is
governed best when many different
nations are given the the are allowed
their independence to pursue their own
interests and their own traditions
according to their own understanding
that's nationalism that as opposed to
imperialism a view that says no the
world is going to be governed best if as
much as possible we bring all nations
under a single rule of law under a
single course of authority and their pie
bring the greatest possible peace and
prosperity these two positions are
completely Eirik irreconcilable and I'm
not saying there aren't arguments on
either side there are arguments but if
what you're looking for is something
like limited government or the
development of individual liberties we
do not have an example of one of these
worldwide empires these empires trying
to unite the four quarters of the earth
that develops this this kind of thing
takes place only in a cohesive nation in
a nation that the term cohesive is from
from John Stuart Mill in it in a nation
that is in which the great majority of
the people feel a mutual loyalty to one
another so that if people come to the
king as they did in England and they say
look
you know you have your sphere of power
but each man each person each man is is
king in his own castle and the King of
England has no right to enter the home
of the lowliest serf without permission
right this is a famous principle in the
common law this can only happen in a
nation that's sufficiently cohesive
where people are sufficiently loyal to
one another so that the king feels proud
to be developing these English liberties
and to not demand absolute authority to
go into any home that he wants and to
take anything think about democracy the
idea that competing tribes that were at
war with one another and disagree on on
substantive matters that they will each
one be willing to allow the other to win
an election and to rule today that's
coming apart in America but a generation
ago that's what happened was that if the
Democrats won they got to rule and if
the Republicans won they got to rule and
if they couldn't rule alone then they
would compromise and they've worked
together I mean again I don't want to
say there was no politics than no hatred
of course there was
but compared to today mutual loyalty the
feeling that they were a single nation
is what made democracy possible take
away that mutual loyalty take it away
and there will not be any democracy the
only way left to govern is through
coercion through imposition of force and
that's why every Empire which is not
unit because empires are not united
they're they're many different nations
they're not united by mutual loyalty and
so every Empire in the end has to govern
by coercion look at Europe like the most
liberal people in the world and they're
incapable incapable of assembling 27
nation nationalities or whatever it is
they're incapable of assembling them
into a democratic country it will never
happen because there is no bond of
mutual loyalty among these people in the
end in order for the
Greeks to do what the Germans want them
to do that if to force them
the Italians just elected a government
they wanted a certain finance minister
and if in Brussels they said no they
dictated who would be the finance
minister in Italy sorry you have to
choose you have to choose between
freedom which is first based on national
freedom if to choose between limited
government democracy you have to choose
between these things and Empire I'm not
so having South not saying anything
maybe Empire will bring more peace and
prosperity but it will not bring more
freedom let me just say one lat last
point about about Empire versus
nationalism nationalism as I've
described it nationalism is a principle
of limiting yourself of saying saying I
want to unify the diverse tribes within
my borders okay and notice notice this
is an important point that that nations
are always diverse all nations are
diverse go back all the way to the Bible
right to the to the paradigmatic
unification of the tribes of a nation
and you'll see great diversity among the
Jews and not only is there great
diversity among the different tribes of
Israel but they also adopt people from
other nations Egyptians left left Egypt
together with with Israel and stood at
Mount Sinai and became Jews Ruth the
Moabitess
she's a Moabitess her descendant is no
less than King David she joins the
Jewish people saying your people is my
people your God is my god so she's not
an economic immigrant although that
factors into the story she's willing to
adopt both the Jewish people and to be
loyal to them as they are flaws and all
and she also adopts the Jewish god the
principle Jewish idea okay so
if we think about this history of
independence nations made up of tribes
not just Israel but the Dutch and the
English and and then the Americans made
up of different diverse tribes but held
together by mutual loyalty in some kind
of common tradition where does tolerance
flourish America has never been as
intolerant in my lifetime as it is today
all right I'm not saying that you know
that the people were you know always
gentlemanly to me when I was a
conservative activist and on college
campus they were not there's always
hatred there's always obnoxiousness
obnoxiousness is like eternal in the
human condition but in those days if one
of us you know we and our magazine the
Princeton Torre if one of us wanted to
write about something we believed in
religious political philosophical points
of view I don't remember anybody being
afraid to speak their truth they might
be unpopular they weren't going to be
persecuted because they said what they
had to say on some subject we talked
about everything everything we wanted to
talk about we talked about it we debated
about it we wrote it we published it it
scares me that those days are gone now
I'm ashamed I'm ashamed that I teach my
children to be careful about what they
say I am ashamed that I teach my
children that sometimes when you believe
something you shouldn't say it
now why is this happening all right
again nationalism as I've described it
is a principle of limiting yourself that
your nation will not go out and conquer
all the nations in the world that you
may think that you have the best way of
life but you're not going to go out and
impose it on all the other nations in
the world which means that national
nationalism is in fact a principle of
tolerance
this was an important point nationalism
is a principle of Tolerance because if
you say there are borders everybody's
always focusing on keeping people out of
the borders you know keeping us keeping
them from crossing the borders that's
not the important part it's important
it's not the important the most
important part is keeping you from
crossing the borders to conquer
everybody else and impose your your
ideas about what's right on the entire
rest of the world by having borders by
believing in borders nationalists create
the possibility of a world of Tolerance
and by creating the kind of personality
becoming the kind of person who wants to
take care of his own and does not want
to conquer the four corners of the earth
and impose his or her ideas on them but
becoming that kind of person you become
a tolerant person and it becomes
possible for you to tolerate difference
in your own society as well and guess
what if you're moving in the other
direction
as we have been for a generation you've
got some new world order you're gonna
impose your values on the entire planet
if necessary by coercion then guess what
so you become the kind of person who
cannot tolerate different points of view
and if you're not going to tolerate
different points of view in Afghanistan
or Iraq or Yugoslavia then you're not
going to tolerate them at home either
and the intolerance that we see today in
America and Europe is the direct result
the direct result of the fact that you
all go to school at this wonderful
extraordinary institution right such
brilliant people such hard work goes
into this and basically you have two
choices for what you're taught what
you're taught here in in departments
that deal with ideas two choices there's
new Marxist universalism right which is
something that sometimes called
progressivism neo Marxism which is going
to bring the revolution to the entire
planet we know the many all Marxists say
we know exactly the way the world should
be run
because we're so smart and then you have
liberal universalism liberal Empire
we liberals we know how the world should
be run the entire planet those are your
two choices total arrogance total
arrogance neither of those points of
view allows the space for anybody else
to exist but you and your values so when
people come to me and they say oh you
know I don't I don't trust salvini
Trump's not my hero look at those brexit
ears boy what's what are the chances
they can govern I say you know what you
might be right but what are you doing
you want to do a better nationalism go
right ahead
everybody's gonna welcome a better
nationalism but you have to be a
nationalist in order to be doing the
right thing and that's why Trump was
actually right this week when he says
there's there's globalists and there's
nationalists the globalists they want
worldwide liberal Empire nobody should
want more lot worldwide liberal Empire
there are some people who don't want to
be liberals there are such people all
right like so either you respect them
maybe you'll take pity on them maybe
you'll hate them but they're people who
don't want to be liberals America will
be able to move back towards being a
tolerant country when there is an
alternative that is nationalist that is
tolerance because it's nationalist and
cares about America and cares that other
nations should be allowed to care about
themselves and do things their own way
as well thank you very much
[Applause]
so we're just gonna open it up to a Q&A
for first question was promised if you
buy it I sign thank you so much
I was wondering sort of about how
journalism in the media like what is
their duty at this like nationalist
framework is their duty to a country or
is it to the world and if it is to the
world was that even mean and so I was
only if you could sort of speak to like
before you were talking about sort of
what's been eroding at like American
nationalism and how a lot of it is
intervention in other countries which
might be distracting from problems
within America and to me it seems like
that like journalism is or the media is
a really big cause of that like a cause
of like misinformation about other
countries and also a sense of like
entitlement and arrogance that we know
what to do so yeah basically what is the
role of the media as it is today in the
nationalist framework well we America
used to have America used to have a a
much more moderate media which you could
call nationalist I mean the there it's
it it's famous that that the the main
media would never carry a photograph of
Roosevelt in his wheelchair because
there was the the White House thought
that it would would not be good for the
for the respect for the presidency or
for the respect for the president for
him to be photographed in a wheelchair
and the the media cooperated with this
and I think this is this is an example
of of bipartisan nonpartisan loyalty to
your president and to your institutions
you you you might have thought that this
was a terrible stupid policy but the
president asked and you would respect
for the president and you you want to
want it to strengthen the country so you
helped now look obviously this stands in
tension in tension with the
responsibilities of journalists to to
pursue to pursue the truth about you
know bad things that are happening
abroad and in the United States
it stands in tension but you know what
it stands in tension the truth is it
stands in tension with with people's
responsibilities as professors with
people's responsibilities as citizens
with people's responsibilities in you
know in a great many occupations the the
the loyalty to your nation always has to
be balanced against considerations of
our evil things being done and and and
and and should I speak out against the
evil things that are happening that that
tension is eternal it's going to exist
forever and I think that what what we
are are seeing in in the last generation
especially is the development of a of a
almost complete lack of national
responsibility on the part of the of
many in the media you could add many in
academia and many and in Hollywood many
in you know all sorts of industries what
used to be a delicate balance so even if
you were a Democrat I'll tell you a
secret
when I was in college I could still read
the New York Times I read it every day
I mean I I knew that it wasn't
reflecting my perspective on the world
yeah I knew wasn't conservative but it
was respectful and responsible enough so
that I could feel like I could get my my
news from there now maybe in some cases
I was mistaken but but you you felt like
it was legitimate and honorable and
respectable to be something other than
what the New York Times editorial line
believed in and I I feel like that's
gone I can't I can't read many of the
American papers anymore I can't watch a
lot of American television anymore
I mean it's it's the the total
partisanship it's being called
partisanship or lack of civility but
I'll tell you I'll give you a different
word to describe it that is maybe a
little bit more apt it's tribalism
it's simply tribalism America is
breaking down into its tribes
and most of the academics and most of
the media and most of Hollywood are
members of a certain tribe and and what
matters is the good of that tribe I'm
not saying it's not happening on the
other side also I think it's a general
phenomenon and when I say I wrote wrote
in a piece in time this week that that
we need actually what an American needs
is more nationalism I know a lot of
people will find that strange
but nationalism uniting finding what
what unites the people finding a way for
the tribes to work together and to
distinguish themselves from others
that's nationalism that's what that's
what America needs right now good
evening doctor thank you for coming and
for your honest words I'd like to ask to
what extent maintaining a national
identity is compatible with cultural
exchange and ideological exchange to the
extent that we see today
more specifically I'd like to know how
do you resolve the tension between the
second stage of the mandate that you
mentioned first you have your borders
and then you're open to teaching your
neighbors and the humility that goes
along with your flavour of nationalism
as in if you have something that's worth
teaching there's still a sense that
that should be propagated around because
it is a certain truth how do you
reconcile that with humility and with a
lack of exceptionalism so as to avoid
Empire great question I think you
described I think you described the
problem very well but I also think you
described the the answer remember I said
my books not utopian I'm not utopian so
I'm not gonna
there's no no formula there's no Creed
that is going to simply solve this
problem this is this is a problem that's
not going to go away but the first step
into to dealing with it is is
understanding the problem the problem is
exactly as you said it that any any
nation worth its its salt as a nation
this comes to feel that it has all sorts
of it has a perspective that's unique in
the world that is better than what most
other nations have produced in a lot of
ways and is something that really others
should should be interested in in
adopting that that's a I think a
completely natural progression in the
development of nations and at the same
time the whole key to keeping a sane
World Order is to speak your mind to
disseminate to teach and not to think
it's your job to concur in course and
you're exactly right that that is an
incredible problem because the more you
think that your ideas are just the
greatest thing the more you're going to
be inclined to go out and and conquer
and course and we've we've seen it for
as long as we have recorded history
so I'm actually at the end of the book
in the conclusion I talk about not just
nationalism as a virtue in the
international order like a something
that the world should strive to move
towards gradually but also it's a virtue
in the individual soul and I take this
very seriously that there there is such
a thing as a completely tribe alized
individual
who thinks that whatever you know
whatever the the leaders the of his
tribe say you know is the truth and
there is no other truth and and if it's
necessary to to do orrible things for
that then you will and at the other
extreme there there is Empire the the
Empire is is is the most fanatical
possible position because because it's
you know like the tribe you think that
you know that your way is best but in
Empire you've already reached that stage
of burning passion where where you know
it can just be imposed on everybody
tribal societies aren't like that they
the tribes they they think their way is
best
they may even destroy another tribe if
they feel like they need to to survive
but they don't have the they don't have
the the burning desire to conquer the
planet that that doesn't exist in tribal
society in in imperial society you
develop individuals right just like in
tribal society you develop people who
are just loyal loyal loyal loyalists in
Imperial Society you that the of course
there are many different kinds of people
but the the the ultimate product of an
imperial state is people who are burning
with the desire to to overthrow
everything in the world other than the
value system that the Empire is
committed to so it's an imperialist
revolution an imperialist revolution
that's what what what what we see for
example in the French revolutionaries or
in Nazi Germany or among the Communists
and we even see hints of it among
internationalist liberals this burning
desire to impose yourself on the planet
the ultimate will to power in your soul
in your soul if you're a nationalist you
recognize two truths that stand in
tension and have to balance one another
one truth that there is extraordinary
truth and beauty in your tradition the
way you and your people understand
things the second thing that there is
also extraordinary truth and beauty
among the nations and that sometimes
they know things that you don't know and
so sometimes you have to learn from them
and not only to teach that balance that
is I'm not saying all nationalists are
like that that's absurd but that's the
the the balance point that it that a
person who understands nationalism
should be striving towards within
himself or herself I think that's a
tremendous virtue in any person who can
achieve that very important in
conservatism however it would seem that
on a global scale on capitalism are
necessarily creates networks of
interdependence between nations and it
would seem that these networks can
sometimes take away some sovereignty
from nations especially if there's a
very big imbalance in economic power in
a relationship but do you think there's
any friction between global capitalism
and nationalism yes there there there is
friction I mean this is I mentioned that
the Irving Kristol wrote this book -
cheers for capitalism and this this
insight actually is very old I mean it's
a at least as old as Montesquieu and
probably older you you find in his
spirit of the laws that he says that
that if your thinking is strictly
economic
if you think only about Commerce and
trading and business then you you you
move towards seeing the whole world as
though as though it's just one entity
because because you want to be able to
do business everywhere now I don't I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that I I mean the the purpose of
business is is is to to allow all the
trading societies each one in its own
way in its own pace to flower and
flourish sometimes it can be abusive and
maybe often it can become abusive and
then you have to deal with it but in
principle it you know in principle it's
a good thing the the the problem is not
the desire to trade you know with
everyone the problem is the desire to
trade in everything okay the problem is
the invasion of capitalist ways of
thinking which are which are
fundamentally promiscuous they're
fundamentally they are people today say
contractual but I'll say promiscuous
that what it means is is if you're doing
a good job but your company decides that
they have a different priority then they
can fire you they don't necessarily have
any loyalty to you and people will say
well economically that makes sense
because companies need to adjust to the
market so they'll fire whoever you know
loyalty is it is let's say kindly it's
not the number one issue okay and the
same with you you work you're taught
we're taught you go work for a firm you
work for some business you for years you
become essential there then somebody
comes along and offers you twice the
salary you know maybe you'll feel loyal
loyal and you'll you'll you'll stick
with with the job at half the salary but
as far as capitalism is concerned it's
just as effective and just as efficient
and maybe much better if each person
when he's valued or she is valued at a
certain level if you're being offered
more at a different company then you
should go so that's promiscuous it's not
it's not based on loyalty maybe some
some firms have have loyalty and that's
good but capitalism is not based on
loyalty take that system I write about
this at some length in my book take that
capitalist system which is so great at
producing wealth and innovation and move
it into the family and have people start
you know eat each each day each month
each year husbands and wives will you
know will decide you know is like in a
nine Rand book is as my husband you know
as good as I thought he could be can I
get a better husband somewhere else yeah
we laugh but it's it's true our society
works too to a shocking degree degree
where it works like like this children
you know everything's based on consent
really well you know maybe 20-30 years
ago I consented to have that child maybe
but not I didn't consent to that child I
didn't expect that and then they get to
be teenagers and they start talking to
you I'm like oh my god I never consented
to this I never did right and what what
can last that way nothing nothing can
last people who people who want to keep
the family a marriage together they
can't do it they can't do it anymore
because they're too capitalists to do it
they kid they don't understand you don't
understand anymore
you people most of you that that no
seriously because nobody says this to
you that to stay in a marriage for your
for fifty or a hundred years right you
change your wife changes everything
changes none of it is what you consented
to right it's not what you can say it's
not what you dreamed of so the only way
to make it through is through loyalty
not through consent through through
saying this is more painful than I can
even imagine I'm speaking to a young
audience when I say this when I speak in
front of adult audiences and I get to
this point and I say you cannot hold a
marriage together without excruciating
pain all them heads all the older people
start nodding nodding you you cannot you
cannot raise children without
excruciating pain but the pain is part
of the process I mean in the end you can
come out of it in in many cases but the
pain is is part of the process that that
in under capitalism when you feel that
much pain you get out and a family when
you feel that much pain you say I swore
a vow I stick and and that's what holds
society together now a nation is much
more like a family than it is like like
a business enterprise my families have a
home economy and nations have economics
and it's important but but a nation is
is like a big family if people are
willing to take the pain on the chin in
order to do
what needs to be done to hold the nation
together the nation can live for
centuries for millennia can become
something really great and if people are
transactional and promiscuous and the
moment things go bad then they go well
well you know I'm not going to be the
laws I'm not gonna pay taxes I'm not
gonna serve in the army I'm not gonna
fight for this country which is I'm just
describing like Europe's already there
and America is getting there
so you're destroying the nation okay the
problem with capitalism is not the
business part the problem with
capitalism is that it ruins everything
else and the only the only the only
answer just like Irving Kristol said was
tradition national traditions
nationalism the religion of your people
these things have to contain capitalism
or it will simply jump across the to
jump out of the bounds of its its course
is the river and it'll flood everything
hi thanks so much for coming and
speaking I want to ask so what is the
plan for peace if there is one in sort
of a nationalist world or at least a
world where people have a nationalist
worldview like I I think you kind of
said like Oh even if it might come at a
cost to peace I was wondering well how
how large we expect that cost to be and
what trade-offs should we be prepared to
make especially in light of the
possibility that like a great powers war
today would leave nothing very good
you're right I I wanted to make my
argument leaving over leaving open the
possibility that there would actually be
that we might take a hit and that for
freedom we would actually be willing to
have less less peace I mean if in theory
right somebody could just conquer the
whole world like it's like a big risk
set right like like as long as there's
competing empires then then there's war
but you could think well all I need to
do is just to win yeses which is where
where America was in nineteen 1989 1990
1991 I just need to win and take the
whole board and then I can just rule
forever and then there'll be peace so I
understand some people think like that
but the truth is that in the book I I
don't I don't believe in that either I
actually
think that that Empire ends up being a
an engine for perpetual war now national
states also fight wars and the question
is whether whether there's a difference
in the quality and the kinds of wars
that are fought when people have
imperial aspirations and I think that
there actually is a big difference I
think that the that when we talk about
war as this existential Menace like you
know killing millions tens of millions
hundreds of millions destroy the earth
when we think of war in those terms
we're actually not thinking about you
know all of these you know petty wars
that were that were fought among the
national state I mean just just think
think examples like wars between the
Irish and in the English or the Jews and
the Arabs in the Middle East or between
India and Pakistan all right I'm not
saying that these wars aren't terrible
but these wars are they're they're
mostly fought about where the border
should be other fought about some
natural and and the natural resources
they're fought about you know like like
you're arming too much and you're
threatening me they fought about all
sorts of things but here's what they're
not fought about
they're not fought about I have a plan
to conquer the entire planet and this
will save mankind if I do this you know
there's it's a vision of universal
salvation which is I mean it it's really
close to a religion and right that I
have a universal salvation theory and it
will save all of mankind and therefore
any cost is worth it now then you get
the 30 Years War then you get the
Napoleonic Wars then you get world war
one in World War two
these these are wars that they're not
just it's not just the you know the the
the the Serbs want elected to take off
some to move the border with the
Austrian Empire so they're so they're
they're they're killing a few people so
there's a war but there's a a border war
between that's not what we're talking
about all the wars I just named are Wars
that are driven by a universal salvation
vision
and if the Communists had ever fought
the a world war it would have been the
same as communists because because
Stalin reverted to you know a patriotic
nationalist in World War two in order to
save Russia but if there had been an
actual shooting war with the communists
then it would have been the same kind of
thing a burning fanatical idea for which
it is worth sacrificing anything paying
any cost and so I actually think this is
not an argument new to me this is this
is a famous argument of Kissinger's
which goes goes back earlier earlier
than him eliminating the universal
salvation theory as a motive for war
eliminates doesn't eliminate but it as
far as we know it it greatly reduces the
possibility that you're going to end up
with with these kinds of vastly
cataclysmic Wars the ones that we're
familiar with they're always fueled by
the burning desire to save the whole
planet which is apparently something
that people can't hold on to while
fighting wars without doing terrible
things so so I'm actually claiming we'll
be better off with the world of
independent nations even on this front
yeah thank you so much for your question
I talk rather I have a question about
how religion about to ask you a question
and we'll see if you thank me I thought
how religion fits into the framework
that you just described
specifically religions that promise like
universal truths and the universal
brotherhood of man so under your
definition of nationalism can somebody
be both a good nationalist and somebody
who believes in like higher authorities
that transcend national boundaries yes
great question
now this book does not enter into
theological questions and that is mostly
because of the preferences of some of
the people involved in the editorial
process but if you want to see my worked
out theology of of
of nationalism and conservatism and how
the pieces fit together the there is on
on my virtue of nationalism webpage or
you can you can google it there is a
lecture called something like god
nationalism and conservatism which I
assume will become a an essay or a book
or something eventually I'll give you
the highlight the highlight is this or
the the highlights are this tribal
societies are basically tend to be
relativistic right meaning that every
tribe has its own god or gods and those
those gods each one rules over you know
like a local value system which you know
the command and the commands of the God
according to its traditions and tribal
societies to the extent that they don't
have any interest in going out and
conquering the world they tend to say ok
over there they do things that way and
over here we do things this way their
gods say this our God say that it works
very very well with with polytheism to
have each tribe have its own God and to
say ok you know down the street there
are different gods in charge the the
Universal Empire thing appears like it
could easily be monotheistic ok and in
fact I think quite a few Christians and
Moslems
have this impulse it's very different
from Jews have this impulse to say well
there's one God in heaven and there's
one Empire on earth you know which is
which is not that's not a made-up
quotation it actually appears in very
various places in history and it's
difficult is very often difficult for
for Christians and Muslims to
to identify with this Old Testament
vision which says there's one god who
created heaven and earth but peoples are
many and they have to do things each
their own way how is that possible well
it's possible because the prophets are
not relativists right they they have no
doubt that there are truths that are
universal right that they they they
believe that some some day all of the
peoples in the air claw on the face of
the earth are going to stop murdering
sacrificing their children to pick an
obvious central example but the but they
have a an epistemology a theory of
knowledge if they can say that they have
a theory of knowledge which assumes
radical limitation on what each
individual can know and surprise even
Moses the greatest of the prophets when
he keeps insisting at the end of the
book of Exodus he keeps insisting to to
know God's essence like there's this
whole story in the book of sxs that
unfolds of Moses wanting to know God's
name to know God's ways and and and when
the when the when when when the Jews
when the Israelites are given the Ten
Commandments and then they turn around
and they build themselves a Idol like a
cow right like a a bull that's a gold
idol and they say these are your gods
Israel who brought you out of Egypt so
at that moment God you know says there's
never been anything so foul and corrupt
in the history of the world just five
minutes ago I told them that they can't
do this and now they're saying that
that's their God and so God wants to
kill them all which is you know that
that's like you know divine justice
let's go let's kill them all he says to
Moses let's let's I'll make a new people
and making new people out of you and the
Moses will not handle this because
and for its really interesting he will
not take this because God promised that
he was gonna save this people and they
lived in Egypt with idolatry and what
now he's gonna kill them all like what's
the big surprise
God promised that he was going to save
this people and now he's gonna back out
of it and Moses has a sit-down strike he
says I I refuse write me out I'm not
participating in this religion and I'm
just I'm out if if you kill these people
and there's this fight that goes on for
like five pages between God and Moses
between this are we gonna go strict
justice or or or or should it be mercy
and when when Moses finally gets God to
agree to let him see his essence right
he wants to know is the world governed
by justice is the it's the same issue
right are you governing the world in
justice or are you just a capricious you
know vindictive arbitrary God will just
kill all these people because they made
a mistake and at that moment there is
this astonishing description where Moses
is at the top of Mount Sinai
we're not the top is somewhere up Mount
Mount Sinai and and and God says well
you can't see my face because no no man
can see my face and live all right so to
begin with there's a whole core to God
that no human being can ever see and
then to see the rest to understand God's
essence God puts Moses in between in the
cleft between is like an ax crevice
between two rocks on the mountain and
covers it says that God covers Moses
with his hand and then God walks by but
Moses can't see him coming he can only
see his backside and when he sees the
God in the past tense in the backside
then there's a description of God's
essence there the the famous 13:13
attributed name of God this passage has
Moses the greatest of all the prophets
according to Scripture
getting God to reveal his name his true
name is true essence and all he can see
is he can't see the face when God's
going by he's covered his eyes are
covered by God's hand and then when God
removed his hand all he can see is God's
back right now this this message of of
humility about what any human being can
know including the prophets that is the
basis for the the political view that
we're talking about that says why is it
that Moses simply can't get a
commandment to go conquer all the
nations of the world and impose and the
answer seems to be because you're not
smart enough not Moses not the prophets
the people are closest to God still do
not have the ability to do this thing
and here there is a an amazing clash
between Old Testament religion which has
its you know that there are many
Christians who are very sympathetic to
this not not just Protestants but also
Catholics i I know because I've been
I've been teaching this for four years
in in to graduate students and
professors there there are many
Protestants and Catholics who are
sympathetic to this to this Old
Testament biblical epistemology theory
of knowledge notice how it clashes with
the Enlightenment this is really
important notice how it clashes with the
Enlightenment the Enlightenment Hobbes
Locke Rousseau Spinoza can't
and all the people teaching you
philosophy and political theory in your
departments just about though all of
these thinkers believe that the human
brain is capable of attaining through
unaided reason attaining universal truth
with regard to morals and politics and
the way things should run that is a
cornerstone belief of the Enlightenment
thought all the empiricists Seldon and
and and and um-- and Smith and Burke and
Mill and and Adam Ferguson all the great
empiricists say this is rubbish no human
mind is capable of doing this but it's
that that that rationalist
anti-imperialist antepers anti
empiricist view the rationalist
enlightenment view which says my brain
is good enough to know the truth for all
men and women in all stages of history
in all parts of the world I know the
final answer that rubbish that is the
basis for a lot of Western imperialist
thinking like Napoleon enters one
country after another and he throws out
their ancient constitutions usually
which may not have been good
constitutions and what does he do he
himself personally writes a new
constitution for every country that he
invades within a few weeks of invading
it he doesn't need to know anything
there's a universal constitution
Napoleon smart enough to have the answer
and that is unfortunately the way many
of our liberal imperialists and Marxist
imperialists think today so that to
bring this to a conclusion I actually
think the only way that you can be a
bible-believing Jew or Christian and
this is this is my view is through
understanding the old testament teaching
about episteme ik humility in terms of
what you can know and that falls out
almost immediately to anti-imperialism
because you can't know enough to run the
world so i guess this will be the last
question but on my questions about
federalism in the United States and do
you see the you know the idea of
federalism which gives a lot of power to
autonomous and gives a lot of power to
autonomous states and regions and
locales over the power of the federal
government as something that helps
nationalism or hurts national
nationalism in the u.s. well it helps I
mean look that is it there's a balancing
issue here federalism recognizes
something we touched with that I
discussed earlier which is that there is
no such thing as a homogeneous nation
all nations are made up of tribes and
those tribes each one has its own
traditions in its own ways and the the
original 13 American colonies are you
know are exactly that same same story
every decent country is you know if it's
a national state and it wants to unify
the nation the tribes of the nation to
unify the tribes of the nation it has to
keep its eye on two different things one
of them to allow the tribes enough of
their own so that their own traditions
their own unique ways of doing things so
that they don't feel like the central
government is like this Empire and
imperial despotic government that's
oppressing them and and and on the other
hand there are limits right because
because there are things that simply
cannot be tolerated and and and maintain
the national heritage so one of them was
slavery and the the attempt to eradicate
slavery by force is something that I I
personally think it was justified and
made sense nicely it's slavery is an
abomination but on the other hand and
likewise I feel the same about polygamy
about the the coercive eradication of
polygamy among in Utah and among the
Mormons I mean these are these are not
liberal points of view these are I mean
this is this is a nationalist point of
view that says we have certain
traditions that and we will not accept
tribes that do not accept those so I
think that was necessary but today
eh I think America's gotten to the point
of America is the the best example of
working federalism that we have and
unfortunately America has really gotten
to the point where many many people feel
many people with a lot of power feel
that that anything that's really
important needs to be decided at the
federal level and that's that raises at
least food for thought
I have a chapter on on on this in my
book I'm in favor of federalism but I
have a chapter called the myth of a
federal solution I don't think
federalism solves ultimately solves the
problem the problem is that there has to
be a enough generosity of allowing each
of the the unique tribes to pursue their
own their own way of doing things and
there have to be boundaries limits to
what you're allowed to do you're not
gonna allow one of your tribes to start
sacrificing children again because you
know they think that being in a neo
Canaanite is just cool or whatever
you're not going to do that so even if
you have to stamp it out by force so
federalism is a is a super and necessary
compromise to allow the National States
to to maintain its diversity while while
holding a certain core of values steady
however the many people who think that
you can just have federalism anywhere
like for example in Europe are
completely mistaken I mean you you you
cannot have a functioning federalism
like you can't have you know the
Federation on Star Trek or or in Star
Wars you know like like like you can't
have a federation where there isn't a
strong bond of mutual loyalty existing
among all the tribes that you're uniting
if you don't have that then no
federalism is going to help you which is
what we see in in Europe and the dream
of a world federal government
which is you know the content dreams the
John Lennon dream my day like there's no
chance there's absolutely no chance of
making that work and we don't have any
examples of it working so luckily we we
don't need to guess thank you all very
much
[Applause]
[Music]